tracking every day the cumulative amount
of your bank accounts is one of the
single greatest things that I ever did
ever ever when you look at your bank
accounts every day you start to get a
pulse on the flow of money you start to
get a feeling for oh yeah Tuesdays is
when this goes out but then what happens
is all of a sudden you're like hey I
went down by 200 bucks let me
investigate and you look in there and
you're like holy crap I've been using
the software for however long cancel and
so as soon as you start doing this you
plug the holes you'll decrease the
outflows of money in your life because
you're tracking and not slacking track
your net worth